This is Dr. Kevin Connors again and we are going to continue our discussion on specific detox pathway.
So we're looking at your genetic report that I would send a patient. This is actually a
practitioner report again, but your patient report is going to look very similar to this.
And again, people ask me, well, how I did my 23V? How come I don't see a report like this? Well,
because you don't get a report like this from 23V. They give you thousands of gene profiles,
whether you have defects or variants or not.
Any DNA software that's going to pull it all off there and look at those thousands of genetic
profiles and put it to some sort of classification. So we're looking at your detoxification capacity,
your ability to get out what's on the inside of you so that the negative things that you're exposed
to don't become a part of you and affect you and cause bad things. So in the last video,
we talked about superoxide dysbutase and canylase and how it works in the whole big scheme of things
with the picture of superoxide dysbutase here and how it feeds down and along with glutathione
gets rid of superoxide ion, which if you don't get rid of it, you cause peroxide trade problems
and will die. So you don't want that to happen. Your next pathway are the salt pathway. This is
how you get rid of a lot of sulfate compounds, sulfur compounds, along with the CBS pathway.
This person looks pretty good. He's got a number of defects in here, but nothing that is going to
jump out and make me want to support it. By the way, with this, if this was a patient that I'm working
with and they had this many SODG defects, this is serious. So it's the canylase here.
We definitely be supporting that and I did not mention that in the last video. I probably wouldn't
support the salt pathways, but we would be doing so indirectly because we're going to be supporting
detox pathways with this person. So there, we would be indirectly supporting them. These nerve
genes are a really important genes. So there's more information coming out about these all the time.
The nerve pathway is another antioxidant pathway in your body and the nerve enzyme breaks down
oxidants. It gets rid of them intracellularly and it's kept at bay by this gene right here,
this KEP1 gene. So this gene right here is a super important gene because if I have a defect
on this gene, I am not going to be able to release nerve in this person. Here doesn't make a
nerve very well. That's these genes right here. And then they don't release it well at all.
Have any defects on these keep pathways? To me, is a precursor for we need to support this because
they're going to have issues on this. They're going to end up with all sorts of long-term problems
with a genetic picture like this. So this is definitely a, we are going to support this with
a product called nerve accelerator that we use. This is, this is a not a good picture. So if yours looks
anything like this, you definitely do not want to not take this. Very, very important to be supporting
that pathway. Keep genes are super important. The cytochrome P450 genes are mainly in your liver,
whereas these are in every cell. These are in every cell. The catalacid SOD genes are in every cell.
Your cytochrome P450 genes are mainly in your liver. This is your primary liver detoxification pathway.
Now this persons are pretty good, but people that have a lot of problems with this gene right here
just let me state. If you have problems with any of these detoxification pathway genes, you're at a
greater risk of toxicity from things that you're going to be exposed to on a daily basis.
And this is where if you want to get detailed into okay, do vaccines cause autism? My argument is
okay, I don't want to say that vaccines cause autism, but I'll tell you right now if you use a
vaccination which has a ton of different chemicals that are put in that vaccine called
adjuvings that have to be detoxed through these pathways and you put a bunch of adjuvings into a
little six pound baby that has a bunch of nerve and keep defects, salt defects,
catalase SODG defects, more importantly the cytochrome P450 pathway and the PON1 pathway
and then at one and two pathway. If they have gene defects that look anything like this person
and you put that into a six pound baby that does not have yet have a brain blood brain barrier,
you know go ahead and play with fire, you're crazy. So there is a deity body under the sun,
I don't care how scientific you are or think you are that can argue with me on this point. I'm not
saying that vaccines cause autism, I'm saying you put any medication or vaccine or chemical exposure
or lead or mercury into a child who does not yet have a blood brain barrier that has a genetic
picture that looks anything remotely like this person's you're playing with fire. That's just
a straight science. So this is okay, I'm an adult now, this was me and my genetic picture,
I'm not going to get any vaccines and I've decided I don't get the flu shot. What are the things I
should avoid? Well you need to support these certain pathways. Personally I would not support
directly the cytochrome P450 pathway on this person. I would absolutely support the keep
and the nerve pathway on this person and I would absolutely support the pod pathway. The pod pathway
right here is super important pathway, how you detoxify vaccines, pesticides, insecticides, large
chemicals, large medications also that that pathways that that wanted two genes support are how you
detoxify those things. Very important this person has a lot of defects on those regardless of whether
they're taking any beds or not. You're exposed to pesticides and chemicals and additives and
flavorings and colorings. I'm not doing any vaccines. Well still you're exposed to large chemicals,
whether you like it or not, you really want to support these pathways. Remember you are what you
don't detoxify. If you can't get them out of your body and you're exposed to some way shape and form
it is going to damage yourself. It is. So do pesticides cause cancer? Well if you can't get rid of it
and it can get inside yourself and it can disrupt the replication cycle in the DNA, that's what cancer is.
So there's no arguments here. They can. All those things can cause those problems. So
quick overview of these detox pathways. Are you want to look for defects and you want to support those
defects so that you support the function of that pathway so that pathway can work better because
these defects were supposed to be there. All right hope that helps. Dr. Kevin Conner is again
share this video if it helps you and share it with somebody else. If you have not had your genetic
pathways done go to our website and you can get this report for you and we can go over your details
like this and share the Liberty Lights idea. I hope not. But it's going to help you save your life
so you don't get cancer and all that kind of stuff. All right thanks much. Bye bye.